the security situation in afghanistan
has been deteriorating for years
but what the security council heard in
this virtual session
was the most grim briefing yet i cannot
overstate
to the council my concern regarding the
present situation
in afghanistan in recent weeks taliban
activity has been focused on a number of
key provinces
these pictures from kunduz in northern
afghanistan where the provincial capital
kunduz city
looks at risk of being surrounded
special representative lyons said the un
believes this may be a deliberate
strategy
more than 50 of afghanistan's 370
districts have fallen since the
beginning of may
most districts have been that have been
taken
surround provincial capitals suggesting
that the taliban are positioning
themselves
to try and take these capitals once
foreign forces
are fully withdrawn the taliban denied
they were responsible for many of the
recent attacks
but afghanistan's foreign minister hanif
atma
told the council they are behind them
and it's a clear breach of their deal
with the us
under the watchful eyes of the
international community
our people have witnessed only the worst
violence of the past two decades since
the
signing of the daughter peace agreement
and especially
since the announcement announcement by
the united states and nato
of their troops withdrawal the massacre
of school boys in logar
schoolgirls in west kabul diviners in
the north
and vaccinators in the east over the
past weeks
are just some examples of the senseless
violence inflicted by taliban and their
associates
after president biden announced the
pull-out of u.s troops in april
his secretary of state anthony blinken
came up with a plan to build on the
talks in doha
with a peace conference in istanbul so
the taliban and afghan government could
work together
that plan now lies in tatters and most
analysts believe the afghan people who
suffered four decades of war
are now likely to face an intensified
conflict u.n experts are preparing
for a major humanitarian emergency james
bays
al jazeera